[Music]
in order to make a full-blown organism
from a cell a cell need to divide but
the cell division process cannot be half
assert the cell division process need to
be highly controlled because
uncontrolled division could give rise to
pathological situations like cancer so
cell division had to be done under
several rules and regulations and these
rules and regulations together dictate
the cells signaling the cell cycle
checkpoint now in the same cycle
checkpoint you can think about the cell
cycle checkpoint or surveillance
mechanism by which cell ensures that its
genetic material is transferred to the
daughter cell reliably and also several
other aspects of the cell division is
not half as earned so the first
checkpoint is the DNA damage checkpoint
at the interface between g1 phase and S
phase the next checkpoint is the
replication checkpoint which ensures the
replications happens error-free the
third checkpoint is a DNA damage
checkpoint it works as a safeguard
checkpoint and ensures that even if some
errors are overlooked in the replication
phase that could be revisited and
corrected using this checkpoint and
another checkpoint is g2m checkpoint
which is so important such that the
segregation of the genetic material
properly happens and this checkpoint
ensures the packaged DNA in form of
metaphase chromosome are properly
segregated into the daughter cells now
let's just first look at the g1
checkpoint
g1 an S checkpoint which is a DNA damage
checkpoint and we would also try to look
at the molecular mechanisms that is
acting in this checkpoint so let's just
look at what happens in g1 phase in
order to in order
for a cell to divide the cell need
instructive cues from the environment
before because if the environment is not
feasible the cell won't decide to divide
if the nutrients in the environment are
optimum cell would decide to divide and
grow in size so the external
environmental cues the mitogenic cues
are conveyed to the cell in the g1 phase
and that often give rise to the
transcription of cyclin d gene and
cyclin D cdk4
complex is the most important cyclin-cdk
complex acting in this g1 phase and as
their kinase so they can phosphorylate
several downstream targets and let's
just see what downstream targets cdk4
cyclin D phosphorylates such that the
cell cycle can move from g1 and can go
to s so in order for the cell to go to
g1 2's the cell need to synthesize
cyclin e because cyclin e would be
absolutely essential at the replication
phase but making site but making cyclin
e also requires elongation factor to F e
to F now normally when cycling for and
cdk-cyclin D and cdk4 are not active
this e to F complex is sequestered by
another gene known as PRP but cyclin D
and cdk4
phosphorylate pRb and ensures that e to
F is now free such that e to F can form
cyclin e and the cell cycle can move
from the g1 phase to the S phase so from
these things we can understand that at
g1 phase cyclin D and cyclin D and cdk4
based mechanisms are pretty important
for progression of the cell cycle from
g1 to a S phase now if there is anything
wrong then the cell can modulate the
activity of cyclin D silica 4.com
Blake's to stop the cell cycle at this
point now let's say one problem occurs
in the g1 phase that is the DNA damage
when the DNA dam is damaged the sill can
understand the DNA is damaged by DNA
damage sensors ATM and ATR which are
kind is in nature they can understand
whether the DNA is damaged or not once
ATM and ATR understand the DNA is
damaged they recruit p53 and p53 works
like a tumor suppressor gene and p53
stops the cell cycle progression but how
does p53 stops the cell cycle a cell
cycle progression p53 induce the
formation of a cyclin inhibitor known as
p21 CIP p21 Zipp inhibits cyclin D cdk4
complex and as a result cell cycle
cannot move further beyond g1 phase and
cannot move into the S phase at this
point inhibiting cyclin D and cdk4
gives the cell some time to cross check
its mistake cross check its error and
try to reboot the system such a way that
this error could be corrected now if the
error is corrected then the psyche cell
cycle progression resumes now let's say
the damage is irreversible then what
happens this p53 give rise to backs
backs is a protein that forms poor in
the mitochondrial membrane and as a
result cytochrome C comes out in the
cytoplasm which interacts with other
components like a puff one and give rise
to caspase activation and caspase
activation can ultimately lead to the
apoptosis of the cell so that's how we
can understand that if the cell if the
inside the cell if the DNA damage is
repairable then the cell pauses and give
the cell enough time to repair that
damage if the damage is irreversible
cell decide to kill it by in a
programmed fashion
so this is how the g1 checkpoint works
now once we learned about g1 checkpoint
let's just move on to the replication
phase and there we look at the DNN ma
checkpoint at s phase now at the S phase
most important function of the ACE phase
is the cell inside the cell is
replication the process by which the DNA
would be replicated into two identical
copies now that process is highly
regulated and requires polymerase alpha
and CDC 45 now Series II 45 is only
active when it is phosphorylated by
cyclin e cdk2 complex and as you can
remember cyclin e and silicate - our
most important components in the S phase
and in turn cyclin e and silicate -
could be working at his face because of
cyclin D cdk4 activity in the g1 phase
now what happens if there is a damage in
the DNA at the S phase that could be
also detected by the cellular sensors
ATM and ATR which can understand there
is a damaged DNA it can give the signal
to certain kind is known as check one
kinase which in turns can activate
another phosphatase CDC 25 and seriously
25 inhibits cyclin e cdk2
complex now cyclin e and silicate two
complex are so important to activate cdc
45 and thereby the normal process of
replication but once series e 25 is
activated due to a DNA damage it can
suppress the cyclin e and silicate -
complex and thereby node application can
happens the cell pauses at the S S phase
and tries to repair it own DNA damage if
the damage is reversible cell resumes
otherwise there are mechanisms by which
cell is pushed toward apoptosis
that means programmed cell death
moving on to the M phase one of the most
important event at the M phase is
aligning the chromosome in a proper
plane known as metaphase plate now this
alignment should be precise such that
tension from the two poles are equal if
the tensions from the two poles are
equal at the anaphase stage the
chromosomes would be segregated equally
onto the two newly formed daughter cells
if the tension is not proper then there
is a chance that some portion of the
chromosome would not be segregated or
there could be unequal distribution now
let's say here in this situation there
is a uneven tension and the microtubules
are not properly attached to the
chromosome this generates an error
signal inside the cell and this error
signal could be detected before we look
at how this error signal could be
detected and one what possible measured
the cell can take let's just see what
really happens in in metaphase to
anaphase transition in from the
metaphase to anaphase transition the APC
complex actually be gray actually
degrades our inhibitor of separate and
thereby activating the separate Sapien
breaks all the cohesin rings and thereby
allowing the chromosome to be segregated
onto the two poles in the anaphase stage
now what happens when the tension is
uneven or the microtubule are not
properly placed there are sensors which
can sense this error such as mad - mad -
is one of the sensor that inhibits the
anaphase promoting complex and pair by
the anaphase promoting complex cannot
activate separating and one separate
cannot be activated by the anaphase
promoting complex the cohesin rings
could not be broken and as a result the
cell at that point of time
cannot segregate the chromosomes in the
anaphase in short metaphase to anaphase
transition is blocked and this makes
sense because when the microtubules are
not properly engaged that time cell need
to pause it and make sure the equal
tension is maintained from the two sides
this is our cell ensures proper
segregation of the chromosome in the two
daughter cells so this is how several
DNA damage checkpoints and chromosome
segregation checkpoints work at a
molecular level if you liked my video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe and please
comment on the video and give you a
suggestion such that I can make my
videos more better